here's Kamala Harris by the way have you
noticed on the show lately I've started
you the people were saying Dave you call
her Kamala and her name is Kamala and
I've I've started integrating that into
the show
anyway here's the vice president that
nobody likes uh and she's getting ready
to ratchet up the rhetoric against you
uh Russia as well
the United
crimes against humanity
I love how she tries to sound serious
with that like cracking voice thing at
least she didn't cackle on that one I
mean guys just trust me they are
ratcheting up getting us ready for World
War III this is what they want somehow
this has something to do with the money
laundering and the hunter Biden thing
and just like this is the new thing War
makes people rich and we got out of
Afghanistan and it was almost like
overnight this War began and we're just
funding it to the Tilt and now he's
doing War he's doing crimes against
humanity guys so he's doing crimes
against humanity those are those are
particularly bad crimes uh we better do
something about it now you would think
that uh zielinski might be when Biden
comes or you know uh crimes against
humanity these are bad things you might
think that zielinski would be like all
right can we get a uh a way out of this
thing is there any way out of this thing
thank you Joe for giving me this
unlimited check and you'll hang out as
long as we want
um but maybe I should make some
concessions too maybe there's something
I could give so that we could wrap this
thing up stop the Carnage stop to death
uh no there's no alternative to Ukraine
and in the EU there is no alternative to
Ukraine in NATO
there is no
no alternative to our Unity
hence there is no and should not be any
alternative to completely get rid of
Russian aggression
wouldn't it be the case that if your
country was being destroyed and your
people were being killed and all of
those things and I am not denying that
that is happening at some level that you
might be willing to negotiate but he is
not only saying go that way the status
quo is not good enough meaning if we
could just go back to the day before
aggression would that be good enough now
he's saying no it's beyond that you also
have to let us into NATO and Russia will
never allow Ukraine to be part of NATO
they don't want NATO at their borders
that's what this whole freaking thing is
about so he's saying to Putin hey the
one thing that you really want is the
one thing we will never give you thank
God I've got old Joe here writing me a
check forever saying we're going to hang
out forever and the Americans are going
to keep giving us money and weapons and
everything else it's it's really just
incredible and it's incredible to the
backdrop of I don't know at this point
with the leadership that we have in this
country and the complete dereliction of
Duty that they've done here with our
borders and our economy and everything
they put us through with covet what
moral right do we have at this point to
be telling anyone what to do I don't
know I think we all have to think that I
think there is a place for the United
States as the world's last superpower to
have a moral right I believe in American
exceptionalism I completely do this is
this country was founded so that
everyone could come here and make a
better life for themselves and then we
created The Beacon of Freedom that the
world has never seen before and may
never seen it again may never see again
we may regret it if we give it up
foreign
[Music]